And Darren's did a lot of prep work
already and conversations as well, and...
So we had some chat, including Isaiah,
and we decided probably the best to do
here is to have a kickoff meeting to get
everybody on the same page. So
The goal that I set for this meeting is
to do a quick review on where we are,
what we know, to create a starting point,
and then
From there,
discussing Terrence has a high level
schedule. So discussing what is needed,
what's applicable for Q3,
and trying to answer any questions that
may come up during this discussion.
Terrence,
do you want to add anything else?
Nothing else.
OK.
Do it.
Right, so I suggest, Terrence,
we start with you,
if you could provide us a quick summary
of the background of this project, and...
where we are today.
Sure.
I don't know how much I need to explain
about what NCIS is.
I think everyone here is familiar with
the project appear. Maybe I can.
Mention what we're marching towards,
that'd be good use of our time. I have...
A request for supporting the networks
firmware development effort which aims at
delivering a utilized firmware that
supports this and other solutions by the
end of the year.
networks will want us to have our code
completed so that end-to-end testing can
be done before they release the product.
So we're marching towards end of the year.
That is to say we
Should ideally start development in the
app services beyond Dan this quarter to
support that activity.
I know we have dependencies on Tommi for
completing system design features.
I know we have competing priorities that
will get on the way.
Like power five and no control switch.
So at this point is, you know,
best said for in my mind,
time to accommodate NCIS development in
observe this quarter in support of that
activity.
I can maybe also add that we now have
features loaded into ADS.
Those have been reviewed by Vineet team.
Some feedback has been provided.
Next step is to review what we said to
that mean we should change in the
requirements.
to make sure that we're fully aligned
across product management and engineering.
And we should probably start reviewing
those requirements with networks at this
point in time.
Here,
we also have a CR with networks to secure
resources.
There is some amount of work they need to
do in support of this project.
I don't know if you were on that call
with Vineet the other day.
It is limited to creating a
sub-certification authority within HSM
for the purpose of signing certificates.
So that that work needs to be done.
I don't know that we have yet commitments
OK.
from networks to do that work by any
particular time frame.
Okay.
Terrence,
do you have something that shows the
network program and the Outcomes program
next to each other?
Because you mentioned end of year,
so what's the milestone end of year?
Yeah.
Is that, what is it representing?
Is that the finish of the end-to-end
testing or the start of the end-to-end
EE.
testing?
So, by then,
we should have done end-to-end testing,
and this is really a question for
networks.
End of year is production release of
UtiloS 58X and X is left at X.
on purpose, so we don't know we need it.
And not relevant for this project,
but also Gen. 5 Riba 3.1.4.
We care only in this project,
we only care about UtiloS.
So whatever networks needs to do to
release that firmware by the end of the
year.
I have to think that they would want full
end-to-end validation before they release
that framework.
Okay.
And do we know what's their development
readiness?
Are they doing development right now,
just waiting for us to complete?
They have included the requested features
in Filward 580.
It has not been tested,
because obviously we don't have support
in-app services for those features.
There's no way for networks to validate
what they did is correct.
But they did build the features per our
Okay.
design.
Document specifications.
Okay.
Yeah,
in the event that we find out that there
is a need for changes in UtiloS,
that will trigger data 58 something.
Okay.
Bye.
So,
networks is on this one is ahead of the
ahead of the curve on on the right?
There is again some amount of work they
need to do in HSM,
and that that work has not been done.
And the HSM is Peter Hand.
Peter Hunt, yes.
Okay.
Is there a...
EE.
Need your firmware component of that.
No, there's none.
What?
Okay.
When is the like integration testing?
By integration I mean DI plus network
which is the Riva Gen.
5314 util OS and our component.
What's the integration time frame for
that?
I had a hard time hearing you, Vineet.
So my question is when is the our
integration with the network would happen?
Like what's the time frame?
Well, they they are ready to go again.
They they introduce the NMNTT features in
UtilOS,
so that the the UtilOS firmware is ready
to go. I I think at least.
No, but see,
even given like the app server will be
start to work on Q4,
and we are also not ready. So,
Yeah.
what my question is,
what time frame we should target,
then we should have all the feature
complete so that we can start some
integration with with with.
Gen. 5, and then the util is so.
Yes.
Right,
so that's part of piecing together a
high-level plan, right?
As what we need to work on on this call.
Right, right.
Okay,
and so one more question regarding so the
so Gen. 5 Riva will not be used as it is,
so which is the current version, right?
So Dina should be interact,
Dina should make sure that the version of
Gen. 5 Riva is.
314, otherwise don't do anything.
Is that a requirement?
Mm.
No, no, no, no, not at all, so the...
There is no new...
Fisher in Gen. Five,
we were needed for this project, yeah.
OKOKOK.
Maybe that's a current version, right?
So then,
so I'm just trying to make understand,
like when they have this project Gen.
Mhm.
Five P14 Util OS 58X,
so that means the current version of Gen.
Five,
making sure it's is integrated with with
Oops.
the util OS, so.
Yeah.
There is a communication between these
two devices. OK.
Yeah, we have only depends on UtilOS now.
If it's making it easier for us to test,
Ashish.
because I don't know if you want to test
multiple versions of Gen. 5 Srivastava.
At the end, all customers are expected
I.
Okay.
A number of different features that we
want to deliver to all these accounts
Yeah.
next year.
So they will all converge to 314.
Okay.
So,
so if it reduces the amount of work that
Yeah.
we need to do,
we can we can say we will only test
against 314.
Okay.
All right.
So, Terrence, do we have the requirements?
Sorry, I think you mentioned that,
but let me let me check again. So,
do we have the requirements ready for all
of our teams?
Yeah, yes, the requirements are in.
Awesome. OK, do can you?
Well,
we need to boil down those requirements
into features.
So we're looking for some system
Yes.
engineering support for that.
So I'm not entirely confident yet I know
Okay.
how much work this will be. So
Got it, got it.
So I'm going to try to sketch something.
Some.
So we're in Q3 and we need Tommi,
we need design work.
From Tommi, right then?
Yeah, that's correct.
And.
Do we have on a high level what are the
key things or?
Embel is them, or are they?
Too much to put it on this table.
Hello.
I think probably not appropriate for this
table. We could probably just go with.
OK.
Design work for for this solution.
Okay,
so we got design and we do some
development after that.
Um...
So are we expecting to finish everything
by end of Q3?
Or do we expect more development?
I'm not committed to that yet.
Okay.
Not committed to that yet,
but that's desire. Let's put it that way.
Okay.
Okay,
so that is dependent on what the design
work will show us, right?
Exactly.
Okay.
Um...
And the design work is dependent on Tommi,
so...
Are we sure no one else can do that?
I know Tommi is out.
Do we know when he's back?
End of next week, yeah.
Looks like.
Yeah.
He's here next week.
No, he was out next week.
No.
He's out next week.
He'll be back the week after again.
Okay, so basically,
and did he provide any like lead time?
Does he need a week or two weeks or more
to do that? Do we know that?
I don't know the answer.
Okay.
Wait, wait, we, we don't,
there are also new requirements that he
has not seen, by the way.
Okay.
Yeah, I am.
Not sure if you knew that there was a
security threat analysis done last
quarter. Out of that assessment,
there were a number of features that our
InfoSec and the networks team requested
as mandatory requirements for this
solution.
So those are part of the requirements
they capture in ADS, but
Tommi has not seen them and he needs to
create features,
system features for those requirements.
Okay.
All right, so for a second, let's assume.
At.
Tommi is doing his part and even
development can be completed by end of Q3.
So what would App Service need to do in
Q4?
Is that bug fix support or some
integration work?
Pulse.
Well,
I I don't know that Dan has the capacity
to do this work in Q.T. right,
that you you have it.
No, no, no, no, Q4, Q4.
You're asking about if we finish,
what would be left?
Sorry.
I don't know the answer to that yet,
obviously, but...
This, I assume,
is all part of the 314 program, right?
Yes.
And so...
That's a lot of stuff in it,
so we'll be busy definitely through Q4 on
314.
Yeah,
but what is what what work is involved in
that?
Is it development or just fixing or
integration?
In the type of work.
Probably integration and bug fixing by
Q4O.
Okay.
EE.
Okay, so that's app serve on a high level.
And we have.
Do we have Dina, right?
Mmh.
So we need,
I think I heard you were saying that
there's development ongoing,
although you have dependency on app serve,
Yes.
but you were able to get some details,
assuming that those will not change.
You will not need to change so much when
app serve is done.
Yeah, yeah,
so there is a there's a requirement,
like go some package request response,
so those are all documented in system
design, and Tommi did that,
and there are a few left,
like those we need a discussion on.
Further continue,
then the dependency with Tommi,
Okay.
but with the app start,
we are like based on the on the request
from the response we.
I'm sorry, Vineet,
I have to stop you there,
so I can't hear you very clearly.
Your voice is low. Okay, it's better now.
Okay, am I? Is it? It's okay,
so we do have some dependency on this
design part based on the template. Yeah,
yes, so that's what we need.
On Tommy's Tommy's design.
Okay.
I already added as a dependency,
so that should be in place for further to
us to continue the development,
and what we are hoping, like,
Okay.
by the time App Service is ready,
we can do integration testing,
so we plan to do it Q3, but Q3.
that it won't happen. So yeah,
we'll in Q4,
there would be some effort in case of the
issues coming out from the integration,
but that's something.
We don't want to get blocked.
There is definitely a dependency.
We cannot do actual testing on the device.
So that is something will be moved to Q4.
Okay,
so that so that part is dependent on app
serve and you've mentioned the dependency
on Tommi's design can change change could
Rai.
No, Miss Dezsenyi.
can change things for you.
Yes, so we.
And the dependency Vineet is on the push
API.
Goodnight.
Right.
Alright,
so that part of the design is captured in
his system design document.
So that at least that portion of the app
services development is not blocked.
Also, yeah.
No, it's not complete.
It's not complete document.
Yeah.
So Tommi knows like there are things
missing.
G.
Not all the custom APIs are defined in
the system design document.
Okay.
All right.
And for for one one thing for Dino,
so Dino will continue to have
Okay, and...
M.
implementation or development in Q4 along
with the integration testing,
so we can have half a block for the
development and for testing.
Got it.
Yeah.
Is it overlapping or is it?
It will be, yeah, it will be overlapping,
so we can continue to test and,
at the same time, develop other pieces,
especially the two-party authorization.
OK.
All right.
Um...
Oh.
Is there anything on the agent side?
Any testing that needs to be done?
But hope so.
I think testing of the of the solution,
so end-to-end should include an agent
that uses peer-to-peer.
Okay,
so only Logan's team will do testing
because there's no functional change in
the agents required.
There is no chance to it.
All right.
So, Logan,
what are your thoughts you see in this in
the screen that?
We don't have much confidence in the app
serve,
Okay.
but also even DI is dependent on design.
Integration can start in Q4 the earliest,
but we're likely shifting based on what
we find out along the way.
Um...
So, what are your questions?
Yeah,
so I want to get a complete solution
overview.
if there is any document to understand,
but from a timeline point of view,
I think like we have to look at this and
plan for in Q1 of 2027.
Mhm, mhm.
Yep.
But if there are things that make sense
to...
check out like early from an
understanding point of view from
developing knowledge it can happen as
things get ready.
But the actual testing will have to wait
for everything to be completed.
It doesn't make sense to do end-to-end
and system test with only part of the
components.
And, and Logan,
I might there is environment set up work
that needs to be done.
Is that something that we can do in Q4?
EE.
Yes, the yeah,
so that's what like actually we should
get a solution overview and things that
we can get prepared for setup.
And then actual test run, test execution,
test design.
Mhm.
Those things, like...
will be in Q1 of 2027.
No,
there's features that we can also get
doing Q4 in my.
I'm sorry, come again?
The test features or a test plan that we
can do in Q4 as well, right?
Yeah, whatever,
whatever is ready to start setting up the
EE.
environment, we can build it up.
But if everything comes,
integration testing completes in Q4,
that is the acceptance point for system
test.
And so it's gated by the integration
testing.
Makes sense.
I put some of these things in.
overlapping each other.
EE.
Right.
If that's okay with you.
Is this discussion including the too hot?
EE.
Hello.
Yeah,
and there is one component like that.
I don't think it is.
I have to look at the overall solution.
That's right.
There is 1 component that I don't think
my team has the knowledge or skills or
equipment to test it.
Okay, which component is that?
Yeah, let me bring up that e-mail.
Hang on one second.
Because there are different components.
Hand.
And Terrence,
do we have that overview that Logan is
looking for, that solution level?
Yeah,
there is a solution document and a
systems design document, yeah.
Could you put it in the chat, please?
Uh, yeah, I have to dig it out.
Give me a minute.
So, as of now,
there are six SSR assigned to Outcomes
Test. Out of that,
two are from two whole P2P.
One is power mode, one is immunity,
and one is...
Keep on and one regression,
so everything will be available by end of
Q4,
or is it like something can be tested
before that?
The reason I am asking is like they are
keep on sending reminders for giving a
date for these six SSRs.
Sorry, I think I pick up,
you were asking about ePone and...
He put it in the chat.
EE.
Yeah,
I can send this full subsystem
And...
Yeah.
requirement as well.
So, as we are,
Peter is only looking at NCIS and maybe...
Maybe we should change that view, Peter,
but I know that.
You are not committed to managing to hop
or EPON, and HPP is finished, by the way.
S.
And I'm not even committed for NCIS,
just saying.
Okay.
Oh.
No, my view on this,
and this is what I told Claus and I told
Steve Hoynes,
networks needs to own 2 hop peer-to-peer,
Ohh.
and they need to own EPON,
meaning from a PMO.
Mhm.
perspective,
they only manage those products and we
contribute. We're part of their core team.
We don't have a project to support those
activities.
The exception is NCIS, because NCIS has,
for the most part, these outcomes content.
And that's why NCIS,
we kept it as an outcomes project,
Mhm.
but the other ones network should run
with those projects.
M.
Okay.
Yeah, so,
so the I think like you're referring to
two hop P2P, right?
Yeah.
And then what about entity security,
entity security?
DI.
And an entity is this?
An entity is NCS.
Yeah, Jessica, give me,
let me move to a room,
do a different room. I'm sorry,
like there is like a lot of background
noise. I have cleaning crew in my home.
So let me go up in a different room,
I'm sorry.
No worries.
Okay, so there are two things, right?
Like a security and two hop P2P.
Those should go to network team.
That's your assessment, right?
as well as EPOM, yes. No, no, sorry,
pardon. NM entity is NCIS.
That's the same thing.
Okay, and an entity, wicked entity,
and this is what we're discussing now,
Okay.
right?
To hope RF peer-to-peer upon.
is network's responsibility.
Okay.
Not to say they might reach out to you
for support with the testing,
but they should manage the project and
they should pull our resources into those
core teams.
KM.
So the scope also includes micro AP right
for Canada.
No, that's networks only.
Don't have anything in the Outcomes
backlog in support of micro APs.
Okay.
So Outcomes like when I now look at it,
it's only the agents app serve and HPP.
EE Yes.
Yeah, and H.H.P.P.
is assigned to Phyllis Stevenson.
Okay.
Should be should be done by coordinated
by her.
Okay.
Rest all belongs to networks.
Yes.
Got it.
Did you get your question answered,
Sajeev, because of the background noise?
I didn't hear clearly. So you asked about,
are there components that will be
available in Q4 that we can start testing?
Yeah,
so that is one thing and the other
problem is like if things are going to be
available for testing in Q1 maybe then
how we will be able to provide a target
date as of now.
Good question.
Sorry, I was trying to get a view.
Because Jason is sending me for the
target date and he sent a second
remainder saying that this should be
ended by July 17th,
that is today or tomorrow.
So, Sajeev,
we cannot provide the schedule now, like,
without knowing, like, the dependencies,
availability, and timelines.
Correct.
So if you are getting pressured,
like redirect the e-mail and conversation
to me, please.
Okay,
so hopefully this is everything assigned
to us.
Right, so I do see.
To all peer to PM, so,
so can you come again, Terrence?
how to hope peer-to-peer is related to
everything else.
So, that's part of the...
Um...
What, what we call the brownfield, um,
well,
I call it brownfield bundle that we're
shooting for towards the end of the year.
So that RF peer-to-peer or two-hop RF
peer-to-peer is...
It is supported in Utilize 58.
And it is going to be supported in Gen.
5 Fever T.1.4.
So how all of this is related?
So networks is looking at this from a
call it a solution bundle perspective,
right?
They're including in T14 and Utilo S58,
all these features that we've been
talking about,
included in two hub and NMNTT. Yeah,
Okay.
and all of this needs to be, you know,
tested and ready so we can release.
Those 3 more versions.
So I see here Util OS to hop peer-to-peer
support assigned to me and to Sajeev.
to Dan.
So it so is this managed by the same
program or it's a different swim lane or
is it part of what we discussed here or
Nope.
is it something else?
Is something else.
Hand.
Okay,
so I think this is where it gets
confusing for me.
So this one is the NCIS only, right?
Is it?
But the program that they are running
includes the RF2 hop.
peer-to-peer, right?
Yeah, includes that,
includes Power Mon for HPP.
Right, got it now.
And includes a e-porn too.
KOK.
OK, so that's the scope of their program.
Yes.
And you're saying that we should be
involved in the first, no, sorry, wrong,
so...
Can you repeat that? So first is outcomes,
because we have the majority of the work
here,
but we do need to support RF peer-to-peer
as well.
Yes,
there is app services work to support
that.
And there is app services work to support
EPON.
Is that upon the the the same upon that
Tommi is tracking or a variant of that?
It's similar, it's a variant of that.
EE.
Yeah.
What Tommi did was a POC build collector,
and now we're working towards a pilot
version of people.
Okay.
And.
Uh, and and H.P.P. is is is,
so we don't need to support that this
group is that your understanding?
Yeah,
that's Phyllis and there's no scope for
us here.
Okay, good.
So we have the time we talked about this.
Now, for two hop beyond app serve,
who else is involved in the two hop?
It's just app services.
Just app services and what do they need
to do?
We need to develop new APIs to support
that, to help our peer-to-peer.
Are those the APIs that we're going to
take over from load control switch?
No, this is this is new, this is all new,
and we don't have a feature for for that
Sorry.
Okay.
yet. Tommi needs to work on the feature.
Okay.
So, Tommi, Tommi, um,
Tommi creates a feature for that.
So, App Service can review the feature,
understand the asks,
works through the details,
and come up with a schedule.
So they do this development.
Do we expect Logan's team to do testing
Thank you.
Logan.
here?
I, I don't know,
so I expect networks to only full
end-to-end testing of the my my one
outcomes to support.
I'm not sure.
We should have that conversation with
networks.
So there was a test review that I
couldn't join, but Sajeev,
I believe you were invited.
Have you had a chance to join this DI
test coverage meeting with Boris?
He has a few requirements and he has the
two hop.
Yes,
but that did not resolve to any
conclusions.
Okay.
So,
perhaps we need to repeat that to clarify
this assumption,
whether Boris Steam will do this or not.
Yeah,
Boris also had a question like normally
all the NPA testing he does and how this
came to came to us.
How this came to us?
In the sense, like,
in already all the NPI project testing
his team take care of.
So he was also asking, like,
what is the role of outcome testing team?
EE.
Yeah, so, so...
Yeah,
so I think like the request came from,
let me look at, yeah,
that was my initial question,
like is it a NPA program and.
I think it came from Jason.
asking us like because like it's outcomes
driven project,
it's a deliverable that networks is doing
for outcomes.
So from outcome system test point of view,
what will you cover and who will be the
lead? That's how it came to us.
All right.
Jason, Jason Bernas reached out.
Yes.
So,
Outcomes from a document and implement
app search changes required to fulfill.
OK, so yeah.
Outcomes GTO is, I assume,
the Lin's team should conduct end-to-end
testing, should the apps such as ATLM,
ATVM are working as expected.
So,
so if Boris wants to take take them on,
like the entire thing,
like because it is the NPI.
That's something that we should discuss
and make sure like the who owns what.
Mhm.
Okay.
Right,
if it's associated with a firmware
program, Boris can take it on.
Right, that's maybe what we mean by MPI.
Right.
Right,
so if it's associated with a firmware
program, Boris usually takes you long.
So,
how about I set up a follow-up discussion
Logan with with Boris and team clarify
this and others?
Yeah, that would be helpful.
Because the meeting that Boris scheduled,
I was traveling, so I was on the flight,
so I could not join.
Ah, so,
so I think there is like what we covered
here is.
You know, Peter,
it it has multiple programs.
So, NCIS itself would be Outcomes.
Yes.
Right, but so, so,
but there is some firmware testing
happening,
and and maybe they will test it against
some sort of firmware program, right?
But to test it from...
NCIS, that's Outcomes then.
Yeah, I think Boris will use test agent,
not the real agent.
Correct,
then the which is that the there is
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
something else which is that P2P, right?
That one.
Yep.
should be a firmware program.
That one is likely not Outcomes.
Yeah.
Because it's...
It's networking. Right, right. Yes, yes.
And then there might be a third thing
Yeah, yeah,
so it's likely gonna be Boris this team.
that we talked about. I seem to recall.
Right.
Yeah, the the Epon.
The epon, right? Epon is,
it might belong to the same category as
number one,
which is there is firmware changes,
but then to test the agents and such.
Right, so to test,
we need to test the end-to-end test
agents, app serve, and EPON,
whereas bottom line is the entry point of
the team that's test the firmware is
slightly different.
Yeah.
You know that, from maybe,
maybe it's a test agent.
Right,
and their focus is start with the test
agent,
then they would test app serve and focus
on firmware. But then for us, we need to..
.
Epon actually is in a weird situation
because Epon,
usually the dev team tests Epon.
Because like now Tracy is himself.
It is really when for the PAC program,
I think it is time to ask.
whether it will get a team.
Right,
because Tracy does the dev and he does
the testing right now.
Yes.
But he may not be as comprehensive in a
sense that, right, there is like,
you know,
you need to put in automation as well,
maybe a bunch of other things.
So it's time to ask, Dezsenyi,
now that we're doing EPON, I mean,
PAC as a pilot instead of a peak.
No, instead of POC, it's an early release.
Um...
whether it's going to get 18.
Because the team.
Yes, that's a good point.
That's a good point, Ting Ting,
because like POC, that's okay,
but for when it is a early availability
or release, there should be a team.
I don't know which team.
Right, but the team,
because the end-to-end really shouldn't
be Logan's team.
It should be the QA of that team.
Right, right, exactly.
So when we talk about we are mixing up
Right.
The.
Right.
end-to-end here with a broad brush and
painting it with a broad brush.
So end-to-end systems test and end-to-end
outcomes system test is my team.
But the end-to-end test,
which is like more functional in nature.
That includes the agent, right?
Focusing on the agent itself,
And.
that is the dev team.
Right,
and I don't know if it is like a Ruchi
Right.
team or like a Matt's team.
Yeah,
so I think that's a question to maybe
Rusti, which is,
is it time for Pat to have 18,
to belong to 18?
Right, so upon.
So I know, so question for Epon.
Which Outcomes teams are involved with
this beyond pack?
Is there anybody else who needs to do
testing with that?
Right.
Okay.
Okay, so that's all, all.
Agre.
I think Logan's team role there is scale
testing. That's one. Maybe he needs to,
M.
yeah, maybe that's about it, right?
Because App Store team will test
themselves. I don't know whether.
Yeah,
so maybe maybe coexistence if other
agents have to reside on the meeting.
Correct. Correct. Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
There is one more item called Power Mohan.
Testing for LNG S4X meters.
I know.
Sorry, speak.
And they mentioned like there is somebody
moved from networks to outcome who did
Ohh.
the power model testing in the past.
What car won where?
Where is Power Mount? Is it for more?
So which heart?
Power mode, it's a firmware changes,
power mode change for high performance
Yeah.
ping,
so that's for peer-to-peer communication.
Okay.
So, it's testing the firmware.
Right.
Right? So not us. Swimware team, go do it.
So if, yeah,
firmware team owns Paramount firmware.
That's it. So Sajeev,
who is the name that supposedly came over
to Outcomes because Paramount is still
belong to firmware.
EE.
It has not moved to anybody in Outcomes,
but I was gone for a month.
So, could you give a name?
On who you thought would own Paramount
Testing?
Not on PowerMount testing.
They mentioned like some results moved
Because, by default.
from networks to outcomes.
I cannot recall his name.
It is starting with Bren or Ben somebody.
Cool.
Oh, no. So Van Dahm, right? BNDAMM.
Most probably.
Right, so,
and that's another question for Rusti,
which is high performance ping. So far,
nobody in Rusty's team has done anything
No.
against it. But is it time yet?
Because it has moved to an early release,
EE.
right? So then it needs to be handed off.
But nothing around HVP has involved
anybody in Rusti's team so far.
And it shouldn't move forward.
There is a project that is managed by
Phillips with resources that have been
testing in the past, right?
That team should take in S4X and do the
testing.
Yes.
Right, right, so.
This, this is not,
this is not this team's problem, right?
That's a different team.
Yep, okay, good.
Like.
Terrence has some names.
All right.
EE.
Hey, I want to jump back to the EPON.
So the EPON that Tommi has been working
on involved a lot of teams and GTO and
everything.
So this variant compared to that,
is that with the same size or how is it
going to be managed?
Does anybody know that?
No,
that's why the question whether it would
belong to one of the colored teams, right?
Then if you get that possession,
if you get that transfer or that
migration of ownership,
then the colored team knows what to do.
And.
So when Tommi did this,
none of the color teams were involved.
So just try to understand maybe my
question is that how is it different?
Purohit.
Cristy.
Oh.
But Tracy was the key guy.
I don't even know what team he's on.
Yeah, yeah, Tracy Theen.
Yeah.
Right, the Tracy team, right?
He did most of the things.
Okay.
So that's why the question,
is it time for a team to own it?
Because if a team owns it,
then a lot of things fall into place.
Yeah, so before that,
I want to ask a different question.
Right.
So is it going to go through the same
steps, Dan? So what's that?
There was meter firmware change,
NIC change, app serve change,
so many things.
What's the scope of this one compared to
that?
Do you know that or does anybody know
that?
Scope-wise,
it's similar to the 311 release two that
was done early last year,
or I mean early this year, late last year,
I can't remember now.
Not exactly the same, but similar.
So does it involve?
I think there's an HF1 on the end too,
hotfix one.
KM.
Crazy name.
Okay.
So, we're talking about EPON,
but what is EPON? So,
was it what is it covering? Firmware only,
meter firmware or NIC or?
It's.
This is this is just for 10-5.
Okay.
I think, right, Terrence?
I eat ****.
Here's that right.
Is for Gen. Five Riva, and also DI Nick,
but right now the focus is Gen. Five Riva.
This program is for Gym 5 Riva.
The 313314 is Gym 5 Riva.
Yeah.
Hey, what for?
There is another program going on.
Uh, actually, two, there's a...
The ANSI products are will be including
the DI Nick Epon and the IEC product will
do a second V where they will be Epon.
So it's all over the place. But
Right.
Too many, too many programs.
Okay.
I would encourage you to name this
activity the 314 Support.
because we have to do separate things for
the June to DI Nick items. I mean,
Okay.
this whole set of charts should be just
314.
Yes, OK.
Yeah, OK.
Alright,
so there's a media firmware change here,
and there needs to be app serve changes
too, and then...
Yep, yep.
I'm going to figure out with Rusti the
pack question,
but then likely other teams will need to
do some level of testing, Ting Ting,
is that what you were saying?
So not only pack, but maybe...
No, so if it belongs to a dev team,
then dev team would do the end-to-end,
right? And then systems,
Logan's team would do coexistence and
Coexistence, yeah.
scale testing.
Yeah.
But the question is, in your opinion,
how many dev teams should be involved
here?
One.
One, okay. Is that the Tracy team?
I don't, that's a question.
That's the question, right?
Tracy does not belong to a team right now.
I know, I know, but sorry,
the question is,
is that only relevant for PAC or is EPON
relevant for other agents?
Ohh, no, so, actually,
I don't know the answer, because I, right?
Okay.
KM.
So, Terrence,
maybe we we we need to figure it out,
but that that's clear, so OK.
I don't think that this EPON work has
anything to do with PAC.
Oh, wait,
packs the name of the never mind.
Right, it is.
That's Waverly, the wad is now packed,
right? Okay.
Correct, correct. It changed me.
Yes, yes. PAC is the new web.
And PAC is POC. PAC is POC. Sorry,
The.
Okay, got it.
I stopped here. Okay.
Yes, it's late.
It's late.
Okay, but hey, so Terrence,
I think before the Tuesday core team
meeting,
probably we should get together with
networks,
PLMs and PMO to realign on these things.
Because I'm expecting if we do that on
the core team meeting.
they will shut down the conversation.
I think the discussion that we had here
would be a good discussion with them
before the core team meeting.
Would you agree with that?
Yes, let's have that conversation.
Okay.
All right.
Do you need contact information or do you
know who we need to have that call with?
If you could share with me,
that would be great. So I...
Oh yeah, please share with me.
Yeah, okay. It's Joe Jason is PMO,
but from PLM is going to be Summer
Roberts and Rodney.
Okay, so hold on.
So, Jason, Summer, Rodney, Terrence,
Peter,
who wants to join that conversation?
This is the pre-pre-core team meeting
conversation.
Okay.
All right, I'll set it up.
So we did some discussion on NCIS more or
less on what are the big activities.
and how they align on a very high level
to the quarters.
And then we did this mapping with EPON
and two hop RFP to peer. So.
For the two hop RF peer-to-peer,
we concluded that this is networks driven.
So the assumption is that Boris's team
will do the testing,
the end-to-end testing in the end,
with verify with Boris and Logan.
And for EPON,
which is similar to what Tommi did before,
but this is Gen. 5 only. Here, it's...
Dev team will do the end-to-end and
clarify which dev team,
and I clarify the Tracy team question,
and Logan's team will do coexistence and
perhaps scale. So,
Power Mon is should be out of scope.
For this group, OK.
All right, so that's all for today.
Terrence,
I set up more discussion with the other
folks and we continue from there.
Thank you guys for joining.
Se you later.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you. Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Thank you.
Hey, Sajeev, get some rest, man.